hello today i'm going to be talking
about stars
coronavirus 2 responding to a public
health emergency
with the lens from a diagnostic
manufacturer
my name is jamie phillips i work at rose
diagnostics in their medical and
scientific affairs as a senior
scientific affairs manager
i obtained my phd from the university of
georgia
in infectious diseases specifically i
studied coronaviruses during this time
looking at the genes that are associated
with
attenuation or pathogenicity
for the purposes of today's talk i'm
going to be going over a background
on coronaviruses discussing the
epidemiology of tsar's chronovirus ii
today and then looking at the different
diagnostic modalities that are available
for sars chronovirus ii
the world health organization was
informed of cases of pneumonia of
unknown origin in late december of 2019.
roughly one month later the world health
organization declared a global emergency
the novel pathogen was identified as
sars coronavirus ii
and was sequenced and named on january
7th
the disease that this pathogen causes
has been named coronavirus disease 2019
or covid 2019
chronoviruses are the largest of all
enveloped rna viruses their genome is
roughly 30 000 kilobases they've got a
large
outer glycoprotein that is named the
spike protein
when you view these viruses under an
electron microscope
they have the appearance of a crown thus
the name
coronavirus these viruses are ubiquitous
meaning they infect many different
mammals
and have different intermediate hosts
with various zoonotic transmission
events
so not all coronaviruses are
this pandemic strain there are
known chronoviruses that circulate in
the human population
and these viruses account for
approximately five to ten percent of all
upper and lower respiratory tract
infections annually
there have been two notable zoonotic
transmission events with chronoviruses
the first notable one was severe acute
respiratory syndrome
which occurred in china in 2002
and the more recent one was middle
eastern respiratory syndrome virus or
mirs chronovirus
which occurred in saudi arabia in 2012.
when we look at these two other zoonotic
transmission events
we know that the intermediate host has
been
identified so for the case of stars
chronovirus 1
we know that the intermediate host was
the palm civic cat
in the case of near chronovirus it had
been
it has been identified as camels
however when we're talking about sars
chronovirus 2
the intermediate host has not been
officially elucidated we know that there
are
copious amounts of virus that were
present in a
wild market in wuhan china but the exact
animal that is responsible for
transmitting into the human population
has not been identified
so let's take a look back at late
january
of the total number of confirmed cases
looking at john hopkins data
we see that china was reporting roughly
2 800 cases
and there were roughly 80 deaths
moving into march we see this virus has
spread globally
and at this point there are roughly half
a million total confirmed cases
and 24 000 deaths
a few weeks later um on april 7th
the count was 1.38 confirmed
million cases sorry moving forward
to april 7th we see the total number of
confirmed cases
is roughly 1.38 million and the deaths
total to 78 000.
early may the number of total confirmed
cases have increased to 3.5 million
and the total deaths were around 250
000. and we see in june
we are now up to 6.2 million
confirmed cases and roughly 376
000 mortality events so
this virus continues to spread and the
need
to identify those individuals who have
been infected
in order to isolate and treat them
appropriately
is paramount
we know that we have learned a lot about
this novel pathogen
and this is evidenced by the number of
weekly publications
that are published on ncbi and
peer-reviewed journals
looking at a few of these publications
we can see that
one study indicated out of a population
in chicago there were 6
369 confirmed cases
of that only 64 or 1 percent
were among children less than 17 years
of age
additionally the majority of these
children were not hospitalized
those that were hospitalized had
co-morbidities such as diabetes or
obesity
looking at another study that
characterized the clinical course of a
thousand patients in new york city
we see the most common symptoms in this
population were cough
fever and shortness of breath we also
saw that patients that were admitted to
intensive care units were older
and also predominantly male and had a
long length of stay
ranging from 12 to 32 days with a median
of 23 days
so at the time of this study the
criteria for testing
evolved like many institutions have seen
in early march the recommendation was
only patients with symptoms
in the hospital mid-march it was updated
to include patients
showing symptoms and those who needed to
be admitted to hospitals
were at a high risk or were being
discharged
to congregate settings in early april
the testing was expanded to all patients
being admitted to
hospitals
looking generally we know that the
clinical symptoms that are associated
with this disease are fever
respiratory symptoms abdominal pain
diarrhea
vomiting headache and malatia however we
also know
that this pathogen causes asymptomatic
infections
where the virus will replicate in an
individual but this person will not
present with clinical symptoms that were
previously mentioned
we don't know how long these individuals
remain asymptomatically infected we also
don't know the extent
to how much virus they are shedding
during this asymptomatic infection
additionally we don't know the
percentage of asymptomatic infections
that steroconvert
meaning would have a a positive
antibody response these are all
questions that we are still currently
investigating at this time
the transmission has been identified
person to person via respiratory
secretions
and incubation period or the time from
when the
person was infected to the onset of
clinical symptoms
ranges from 2 to 14 days with a median
of 5 days
we know that clinical progression occurs
and this
virus can cause severe respiratory
disease
leading to hospitalization and mortality
events
so when we look at the clinical stages
of covid19 we can break it into three
different stages looking at
this chart here we see that severity of
illness is on the y-axis
and it's the time of course on the
x-axis
so for stage one it's been identified as
an
early infection individuals are going to
be presenting with
mild symptoms such as fever dry cough
stage 2 we see that it's a pulmonary
phase
and during this time you see a shortness
of breath
hypoxia stage three
you see it's called the hyper
inflammation phase
and you see a large increase in the host
inflammatory response
here the clinical symptoms can consist
of ards
fears cardiac failure we know that there
are elevated biomarkers during this time
point such as crp
ldh or even il-6 which has recently
received
eua for this designation there are
current potential therapies but for the
purposes of today's talk we are only
going to be
discussing diagnostic modalities
and we do see that the majority of
patients
typically only fall into this early
stage one
so there's two critical features of a
successful response to a pandemic
one is the early detection of infected
individuals
and two the isolation of potentially
infectious individuals
and so in order to properly detect these
individuals
we need to understand the testing
formats and their
purpose so as of current there are
available tests that are molecular tests
anagen tests and serology tests
but in order to understand how we can
utilize these tests
we really need to understand the stages
of transient viral infections
so typically a person gets infected via
the respiratory droplets the virus
enters the host cell and then hijacks
the host cell to manufacture
more of itself uh the immune
system will start to respond
due to this replication typically the
first immunoglobulins that are present
are going to be your igm
these are your pentomers and then as the
disease progresses you're going to have
a selection process of high affinity
immunoglobulins
that are typically neutralizing and
ultimately
the ideal situation is that the virus is
eliminated
and the individual recovers
so when we are looking at these tests
we need to understand what we are trying
to find out in order to decide
what modality should be used if a person
is currently infected with stars
chronovirus and we want to understand if
they
are or are not then we would want to be
using a nucleic acid amplification test
a
nat test which be it would be
identifying the genetic material
of the pathogen or an anagen test
which would be identifying an antigen of
the pathogen
as opposed to if we were asking the
question has a person
previously been infected with stars
chronovirus ii
if this is the question we really want
to be using a serology test
to identify those antibodies that are
present
due to the infection so when we look at
the infection we can see here the
estimated course
of molecular and theological biomarkers
so you can see that the dotted line
here indicates symptom onset
and so we talked about this virus having
an incubation period
a period where the individual is exposed
to the pathogen
but doesn't necessarily present with
clinical symptoms
at the time of symptom onset you are
near peak viral replication and so
it is optimal at this time to be
utilizing
uh you know pcr or another form of nat
or an antigen-based test however as the
disease progresses
you can see that you're by week three
in between week two and three is your
median day of seroconversion
meaning that you will be uh
immunoglobulin positive
and there is an instance where an
individual could be positive for pcr
and positive for the immunoglobulin so
that's important too to understand how
you could get
both of those results depending on where
the individual is
in the course of the infection
so what we can see here is that there
are many targets
for sars chronovirus to diagnostic tests
this virus has several proteins the
membrane protein the envelope
and the spike protein as well as a
nucleocapsid
protein that all can be identified
the immunoglobulins or the serology
assays
again are identifying the immune
response
to these specific antigens
so let's look at what the cdc as of may
6
was recommending as a priority for
nucleic acid or
antigen test at this time they place a
high priority on hospitalized patients
with symptoms healthcare facility
workers
workers in congregate living settings
and first responders
again with symptoms they also placed a
high priority on residents in long-term
care facilities or other congregate
living settings
including prisons and shelters with
symptoms
they updated this to include priorities
for also
with persons with symptoms of covid19
infection
including fever cough shortness of
breath chills
muscle pain new loss of taste or smell
vomiting or diarrhea and or sore throats
or persons without symptoms who have
been
prioritized by health departments or
clinicians for
any reason
so let's take a look at this timeline
above the months
you can see roche specific activities
and below you can see rest of world
so just to reorient everyone
late december is when the first report
of the unknown
pneumonia cases were reported by
february 14th roche had manufactured
a research use only assay that was
available
in the u.s march 13th
roughly one month later roche received
their
e-way for a high-throughput molecular
test
so this test could be run on two
different platforms the 6800
or the 8800 and it was identifying
three regions of the
genome of the virus so again this is
looking at the nucleic acid
the intended use was a qualitative
detection
of this nucleic acid and the specimens
could be
clinician instructed self-selected nasal
swab
or clinician collected nasal
mesopharyngeal
and orphan gel swabs so a positive
result
was indicative of the presence of sars
chronovirus ii
rna
these are the two platforms that this
test could run on the 6800 is on your
left the 8800 is on your right
and respectively these two platforms can
yield about
384 results or 1800 results per
eight hour shift
so going back to this timeline we've
added a few months on here and we can
see that in may
roche launched a anti-sars chronovirus 2
assay so this is a serology assay
identifying if an individual has been
infected
additionally a current date looking at
june the pipeline for stars chronovirus
as assay specific for point-of-care use
are underway
so briefly going back to the
zorology assay that was launched in
early may
we know that there are many antibodies
that can be identified due to the host
immune response
and typically you know as mentioned
earlier in this section you see the igm
and as the disease progresses you
end up with high affinity igg
so we know that the test is able to
detect these high affinity igg
immunoglobulins but there are still a
lot of unanswered questions
some of the things that are still
currently being researched are
is this immunological response
protective
and does the presence of antibodies
indicate immunity
and if so how long does that immunity
last
a question that i know is top of mind is
how long will it take to reach herd
immunity
um via either infections or vaccinations
and so there's still a lot of unknown
information that hopefully will
begin to be published within the next
few weeks
so let's take a step away from the
molecular
and the immunoglobulin tests that are
high throughput
large tests typically operated in a
laboratory and let's talk about some
point of care test
specific for stars chronovirus too so we
know
that there are molecular point-of-care
tests
and these platforms are often small and
portable
and are optimal for deployment to remote
or outbreak in crisis situations
these have a much lower throw throughput
though in comparison
to the aforementioned molecular tests um
and typically you can run one sample at
a time
anywhere from five to thirty minutes so
because of the low throughput and the
time that it takes for a single sample
really these tests are not feasible to
test say an
entire manufacturing facility of a
thousand employees
however they can be extremely useful
in situations where you have a
critically ill
patient who needs to have a diagnosis
within minutes in order to impact their
care
so there are several eua approved stars
chronovirus ii molecular point of care
platforms
what's important to note is that they
they all differ
so many times they're targeting
different regions of the genome
they have different analytical
sensitivity claims
they have different throughput different
hands-on time as well as different assay
run times
but all extremely useful in different
settings in addition to the molecular
point of care test
there are antigen tests that are on the
market
and more to come and so these diagnostic
tests
quickly detect fragments of proteins
that are found within the virus
it's thought that these tests are
typically less sensitive when comparing
to
molecular tests because there is no
amplification
step in the traditional technology
of these tests
the last potential point of care test is
the
antibody test and again much like the
aforementioned
high throughput serology test these
tests are identifying immunoglobulins
but again they are single use low
throughput
and lateral flow technology
so they're simple to use oftentimes
the sample can be collected through the
use of a fingertip
finger stick
so again the limitations in our
understanding
around the immune response still exist
but i do foresee these tests having high
utility in the future
as some of these answers become
available
and so with that i would be happy to
discuss
any of your questions thank you so much